[Applause]
thanks mike here with john moran john
you are in the nba playoffs how does it
feel feels good
man first time uh you know we
we battled all season had a chance
you know to go my rookie season uh just
fell short you know a couple of games
learned from it knew what we had to do
and you know now we're here
you hit those two floaters at the end of
overtime just
huge pressure on both of those shots
what is your confidence level when
you're approaching the basket like that
that's the shots i want to take uh you
know i like when the pressure's on me
you know it
uh just you know uplifts my game um you
know i got all the confidential world in
my game and
you know late uh coach tried to you know
set a screen
i just told him to move you know i want
that pressure
you are 21 years old your team overall
is the youngest squad to make the
playoffs in 10 years
the last guys to do it at this age where
the oklahoma city thundered that team
with k.d with russell westbrook with
james harden
how are you guys able to show such poise
in pressure situations when you play
teams so much more experienced than you
oh man you know we just go out and
battle you know we know we're a young
team
uh we have some vets you know that you
know coach us up
um and lead us man and then you know me
being you know the point guard i have to
be a leader
uh obviously you know um it's my first
time you know making the playoffs but we
have some players you know who
been in the playoffs before so you know
they're going to help us out you know
let us know what to expect and then
we're just going to go out and you know
play our basketball and you know battle
all 48 minutes well you said when you
left to come to san francisco you were
packing for a three-game road trip and
in fact you are now off to play the utah
jazz
best record in the league this year what
can we expect from that series
um my fight man you know uh we played
him you know early in the season
obviously you know
came up short i think like twice um
i mean the best team you know in the
league right now so you know we know
what to expect
we just got to lock in you know on our
game plan and
play 48 minutes well take a minute to
enjoy this one first congratulations
john moran and the memphis grizzlies
appreciate it
back to you mike